what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be continuing my series of
investigating the court system in the UK
and today I have a special guest
introduce yourself to the people hi my
name is farook
um I'm from London England going for the
family court system I've got a small
channel can I mention it yeah go ahead
I've started a channel called
disqualified dad's trying to expose and
highlight the family court system and
the horrors that go on basically behind
the scenes that no one is aware of
ultimately okay so um your channel is
called disqualified dads is that an
organization too or is it just a channel
it's a Channel slash organization
because I've used the little knowledge I
have and the little traction that I've
had to help join other fathers groups
together so it was a small platform but
hopefully it'll have a big impact that's
what I'm hoping okay so what is your
experience with the court system in the
UK
right I'll try and frame this in a way
where I can explain how I've seen it so
I'm 41 years old I have met and worked
with a lot of people I've gone through
separation divorce and you know
obviously men don't get a great deal but
you don't understand the full horrors of
it until you enter the system so I work
with guys we're going for a divorce and
I'm like listen mate just get through
the day let's get the job done you'd be
all right but you have no understanding
of the horror that they're going for
especially if they're going through
courts now once I entered the court
system myself
um basically March the 16th I ended my
relationship for various reasons
multiple of issues you said March 16th
2022 sorry so 2022 you ended your
relationship and that was a marriage
that was just uh it wasn't a civil
marriage it was it was more just an
Islamic registry but we were married
religiously from a religious perspective
so it was not a legal man it was not
illegal marriage but it was a um a
religious ceremony okay
and so in 2022 you ended it yeah so 16
for March 2022 for multiple issues and
reasons I ended it after 10 years that
is just to highlight yeah okay now
follow following that day it's like I
remember that day clearly so March the
16th wrapped it up that same evening I'm
arrested and taken to a police cell for
24 hours
historic allegations of every type of
abuse you can imagine
the same day yeah the same day so did
she see it coming then or was that just
the initial yeah this is the other thing
and because of what I now know after
getting into the system everyone I speak
to the blueprint is the same you're
arrested
they go to have a women's Refuge or to
any or the specific women's group
after that they secure legal aid and
then after that you are systematically
dismantled now the thing is
every father that I speak to now and
we're going into the hundreds of fathers
now yeah the same blueprint it's like
they knew they knew exactly what moves
to Paul what to do how to do it and
before you know it you're homeless
you're literally just thrown out onto
the streets you can't tell anyone you've
got a court order against you which is a
non-molestation order so
and you're just literally left out to
just survive on your own even if you
have nowhere to go literally so so
basically March 16th I end it I'm
arrested
and then she just sorry to cut did she
go to a women's group that day or had
she been there before no okay let me go
into this now because I notice in detail
what happens is weeks when they notice
tension in the air what happens is you
go to the doctor or you speak to your
friend's Circle someone knows someone
someone already knows the blueprint so
they say go to the doctor you put in the
tears you say you're depressed you're
being abused and now with the law around
coercive control which is coming to law
which could mean anything coercive
control could mean absolutely anything
so they go to doctors or the other one
is when they're dropping the kids to
school and back you go to school and
back you put on the tears in front of
the teachers in front of some Authority
okay they then refer you to the relevant
women's Aid groups I've had a doctors or
the school teachers or something like
that they refer you to these people when
you go to these um I don't know if I can
say the women's Aid group or whatever it
is they will map out a blueprint for you
and when I say they map it out in detail
they will look at your background so for
example if you're a Muslim man yeah they
will say you need to this is what's
happening in a family court so
specifically against say Muslim men I'll
give you an example they say right give
us your history you've got a few
problems you've got some arguments
firstly they say you need to demonstrate
there was a threat of um he was going to
kill me there's a threat to your life so
they say for our arguments say the
coercive Control Card they'll say five
years ago you had an argument about the
color of the wallpaper you disagreed
with her that's coercive control then
they say add to that card you threaten
to kill you afterwards for example after
the argument that's danger coercive
control they they have this belief so
how how do they do that if there's no
evidence that he did that in the family
court you don't need any evidence so she
can just say that he we disagreed on the
wallpaper and he abused me after and
there's no she doesn't need any
Witnesses this is The Madness of it all
okay The Madness of the law and the way
I've seen the coercive control argument
is
if you're a man and you disagreed that's
coercive control wow this this is what
people understand when I say the horrors
people have no ideas when you're
standing there thinking hold on the
grown-ups are going to get involved
they're going to sort it out I'll have
access to my kids they'll tell her that
he I didn't do anything it was a normal
healthy argument
but they don't do that the family courts
Pander to that behavior and this is then
this is not one case these are thousands
of cases you could have a cue a thousand
men out here just like that here and
when I say what happens so they go to
This Woman's Day group and what they
then say is right you're from a Muslim
background right you need to say your
husband's a little bit extreme he's from
an Indian background he's got backward
viewing women he looks down on women so
you've got the honor card and the
extremist card they call it a religious
card the other for example if there's if
you're from a military background they
say right you need to add to that he
suffers from PTSD
um and he's seen a lot of action so
hence he's unpredictable we have so many
cases they know which words are going to
work in court exactly they have a case
where if he's an Englishman they turn
around and say he likes to get drunk
after football if he's in a bad mood
then he attacks they have they have a
narrative for every single scenario
background culture you can imagine it
can be weaponized within the family
court and so in the women's groups those
are the ones that are pushing this so
like say for you hypothetically you guys
were having problems she maybe saw it
coming and then she went to either a
teach someone knew something no this was
yeah so this is what I'm saying we had
problems but the blueprint my blueprint
was laid out from years ago because when
men are in these relationship you go to
work you come home you sort of got your
kids you know things ain't great but
you'll Soldier on for your kids and just
for the record I would have sold it
until the end for my children but
because the control elements start
affecting my children I had to take a
stand for them so what would they say it
for um a Nigerian guy classic cultural
concerto he's now dreaming looks down on
women you know the whole world he
believes in having three wives and in
Nigeria they they're allowed to hit
there is any any card you can imagine
right
because you've got to understand women's
Aid effectively they Leverage The Family
Court they train up the Kafka social
service service officers that go and
interview the parents in these cases
they leverage child maintenance do they
train who right so you've got an
organization called Kafka I know we're
getting all I'll try and yeah I'll try
and bring it I'm trying to understand
like the okay the mechanics yeah so
because I'm trying to understand the
system just you know that's the
recording so he'll just replace that so
first
they
go to a doctor go to your GP you put on
the tears and you know you can't be
depressed and all of that sort of thing
okay so that's step one and the doctor
can refer you also to the women's AIDS
group for support the women's Aid okay
so when they go to the women's Aid group
women's they'd have a blueprint of how
to secure the children secure the
finances and basically come out fully on
top okay and they give them the full
blue blueprint
finances
so they first go to a GP and a lawyer
then they go to it just a GP or a
teacher yeah or teacher or someone of
authority who can then refer them to say
This Woman's in danger
she can't speak out we need to refer to
woman's idea okay then they go to
women's eight yes women's they give you
the blueprint they say right what
allegations are you going to make X Y
and Z and then when the individual is
ready they can pull the trigger call the
police because once you call the police
you've now got it on record husband of a
boyfriend gets taken away okay and once
you've done that that's on record that
secures legal aid
okay that's the other thing so you have
to do that to secure legal aid
okay so if they make those allegations
they make because in 2013 the legal aid
mandate in this country changed so they
weren't just going to hand it out just
like that unless you were a victim of
abuse so straight away
that year 2013 just in Birmingham
Birmingham alone they said domestic
abuse or these sort of abuse allegations
went up by 200 percent wow funny that
and it's as soon as they change the
legal aid mandate 200 just in Birmingham
along yeah okay so imagine across the
country it's a lot it's a lot more but
legal aid like I said mandate came in
abuse allegations went through the roof
and you need legally to then secure
everything else and the government are
sponsoring that effectively for legal
aid okay so then they get legal aid
what's next they take you to court once
it's legal aid they don't take you to
court this is what they do they apply
for what you call a like in America
would be calling the restraining order
so it's like here is called a non-male
station order
the non-molestation orders now let me
tell you what evidence you need for that
absolutely zero zero evidence okay you
made allegations you've gone to the
police you write a statement of random
allegations you can literally say
anything you want or whatever the
blueprint that you were given by the
women's age yeah
depending on your background culture
whatever card they need to use they can
put it in there yeah that is submitted
to the judge without your knowledge one
morning you wake up you've got an email
a WhatsApp and a letter saying you can't
go to your home you can't go within 100
meters of your home you can't get in
touch with her you can't call her so the
men have no heads up until this you have
no one let me I'm writing I'm writing
this down let me tell you something when
I say you have no you are not so sick
from political you have no idea so
you've just broken up imagine this
you've just broken up yeah depending on
the sort of relationship you've had the
kids are 90 of the times with the mother
or the uh yeah with the misses basically
yeah ninety percent of non-resident
parents in this country are men
non-resident parents
10 older women yeah so the chances are
she's either going to leave the house go
to her moms or friends or relatives
anyway yeah so you've already lost a bit
of contact there what happens at that
point is once the non-molesterion order
comes in even it says on the non-molele
stationary you can make contact to have
access to your children but if the
mother at any point says oh he's
victimizing me or I'm scared police will
come and get you lock you up no
questions asked you are walking on edge
literally and this order is served
without any notice
and no evidence either no and so you
could go to jail she could just say oh
he beat me with no evidence and you
could go to jail no no you don't go to
jail so they serve this order on you if
she feels if she says that she feels
threatened or harass her even if you say
upload pictures of your children on
social media mum complains to the court
saying oh look he's breached his order
I'm being stressed because he's done
this police will come and get you you
have to close your social media take
your children's picture that's how
brutal it is yeah but if you overnight
get told you can't go 100 meters within
your home effectively you've lost
contact with your kids your potentially
homeless and on the street so you could
be working and earning you own a house
but you're literally homeless so you
have to manage and get by and just sold
for Surf and however you can I
personally lived in my van for many
months I still sulfur surf a year in I'm
still doing that yeah
but because once this order is served
what the court says you've got two weeks
normally to come back put your case
forward whether they'll either discharge
it they'll vary it or they will extend
it fully for a year now nine out of ten
times they hand it out like sweets so
you go back after two weeks you say look
judge I didn't do X Y and Z have you got
any evidence I have nothing like you
don't keep records of any arguments or
anything you know it's very hard to
prove when no one was there so
ultimately because you're a man you
expected to manage yourself don't worry
we'll stamp it and that's it you're done
potentially for six months to a year
you're out of your house
is that different than the restraining
order that is a restraining order but
this they call it non-molesterol that's
the full name okay and so you have
essentially a restraining order like
because typically if you don't I just
want to make sure I'm understanding so
after two weeks if you have no evidence
that you didn't do it then
um which how how would you right in a
10-year marriage
um then the judge will most likely
extend it for a year let me put it this
way from from what I've seen and what I
know in all the fathers I spoke to is
you're basically going there just to say
for the judge you just stamp it and say
yeah I'm extending it is they're giving
out like sweets last year they reckon 40
000 non-molestation orders were dished
out wow they are dished out like sweets
the the threshold of evidence is so this
is what when I say I talk about the
brutality and the horror people have no
idea this one's saying so you're now
homeless you've lost contact with your
kids you're emotionally all over the
place you've just split with a long-term
relationship now my situation and I
ended it but the hundreds of files that
I speak to even in my community their
their wives ended it basically they had
no choice so they've literally overnight
lost contact homeless and you just
literally left out in the wilderness and
what happens is then is then the
downhills down sorry the downhill spiral
start so you you're walking around
you're very emotionally charged you
ain't seen your kids you don't know when
you're going to see them the emotions
run high up and down then you you're on
the streets you start drinking drugs
gambling 10 men A Day post separation or
committing suicide it doesn't even make
the mainstream News 10 women a day are
committing suicide yes they've average
studies and research that I've seen and
looked into they're saying they've
averaged it 10 men a day and the child
May I'm sorry acted that so after the
non-molestation or two three weeks in
you get child maintenance phone you up
if you if you work as in pay like you
work for a normal company or an employee
they have all your records of you they
know what you earn everything straight
away
so straight after that the application
goes in right yeah for child maintenance
so you're already all over the place
child support child support no one in
America's child support okay they then
phone you and they they literally
financially
um they literally financially violate
you and if you don't pay whatever money
they decide that you need to pay
they can take you straight at your
account so what happens then is you're
already paying all the bills this is the
realities you're paying all the mortgage
bills all the stuff already for your
house that you lived in you are now
homeless now you pay child maintenance
on top of that
you're left with no money so you can't
even rent out an apartment or anything
and when you experience to child
maintenance they do not want to know
cow maintenance are responsible I just
want to put this out there they've now
said for a thousand male suicides a year
child maintenance in this country are
responsible and there are organizations
that are trying to take them to court
now
that I'm working with a thousand male
suicides a year from child support child
support the harassment is the way you
are treated sub-human can I I just want
to um so if a guy is making 5 000 a
month how much would he pay
I think they average it on your annual
earnings so if you were earn and this is
before tax just to clarify as well so
they calculate child maintenance before
the tax is deducted so if you were say
earning fifty thousand pounds fifteen
thousand pound is
um fifty thousand pounds if you're
earning fifty thousand pound a year so
say Okay 50 Grand a year yeah
out of that the government will take
their fifteen thousand pound tax what do
you call it yeah Inland Revenue they'll
take their tax but child support will
calculate the percentage on the fifty
thousand not for a tax yes okay and I I
would say if you're earning about if
you're only five thousand pound a month
I reckon you're looking at at least this
don't quote minus but at least 1500 quid
already really yeah 15. 1500 if not more
because 5 000 if you're consistently
earning five that's a lot of money I
would say about 1500 pound it can
potentially come after you and you're
still paying all the other bills and so
and that's a good start just to
highlight five if you're taking home
five thousand pound a month are you
saying taking home or pre-test no just
pre-tax okay so let's put that figure in
reality here after tax that'll be about
maybe three you're taking on 3 000
average year now take a thousand fifteen
hundred pound out of that what are you
left with
you won't even pay your you can't you
barely cover the mortgage of the house
and would she like are you required to
still pay for the house yes if it's in
your name mortgages you still have to
pay because if it's in your name if you
don't pay for look if you've just
separated and you've even had a joint
mortgage there's a risk of repossession
and you've all your finances are
invested in the property so you have to
keep paying wait so let me get this
straight she stays in the house yes and
she she gets a restraining order against
you so you can't even get in the house
that that you pay for
and then on top of that you have to give
her a thousand five hundred a month on
the potential it varies that could be a
thousand could be 500 could be more it
could be two thousand we don't really
know it depends on the case but but so
on top of that you have to give him a
thousand or her a thousand five hundred
a month if you're paying all the bills
let's say so how how would you not get
homeless then because it's like how
could you this is what I'm saying people
have not when you try and plead these
people to child maintenance I can and
this is now they've done a survey when
they talk to you even the way they treat
you and talk to you and what people
don't realize in this country they
presume child maintenance part of a
government Authority child maintenance
the CMS are an independent contractor to
the government they make money off a
child they made so many billions of
child maintenance over the years but
people assume it's a government
organization it's not it's an
independent contractor and the child
maintenance is also leveraged by women's
age there's people have done research
and they said child maintain have a lot
of Leverage over not sure I mean women's
Aid have a lot of Leverage over child
maintenance what do you mean leverage as
in the the CM I'm not a CMS the women's
Aid are so powerful as an organization
like I said the social workers that work
for the family courts here that decide
whether you have contact or not they are
trained up by women's Aid
yeah so they leverage kafkas which is
the family court Social Services women's
they Leverage The Family Court they have
more leverage over Kafka and they have
leverage over child maintenance and
recently
I'm saying recently over the last few
months there was a law that was going to
be passed with that child maintenance
will have enough powers to put
electronic tags on non-paying fathers
Matt O'Connor years ago highlighted in
one of his interviews child maintenance
had the power to revoke your driving
license and your passport at one point
in this country I remember hearing these
things many many years ago when I was a
lot younger but the horror of that never
resonated until you end up here and then
you see the absolute horror of it so if
you don't pay for child support then you
might get your passport taken I don't
know if that's still in place that was
years ago they had powers to do that
what they can they can also go into your
back what they can do now is they can go
into your bank they can get a court
order go into your bank accounts at your
savings they can literally take money
out okay this one's saying when I say
you are violated like through litigation
when people talk about tyranny horror
and oppression I'm physically I might
look alright here physically yeah but
when you sort of through litigation
destroy a person this is how they do it
I've seen how they do it and we talk
about demasculation this is exactly how
it's done you have no fight left in you
hence the suicide rate
and child and child child maintenance
likes to through their harassment
thousand men a year after just just
through child making dealing with child
maintenance or committing suicide that
you were destroyed you are mentally
emotionally destroyed because you've
spent your whole life working to get to
this point and then you're you lost
everything you own pretty much you're
not going to come in London to say
you're going to start again at 40 45 50
and go and buy it probably it's not
going to happen you're dumb wow you are
done
and the thing is this even if you're not
married legally because they have the
children number one right if you have
children and you the key to all of this
is the abuse allegations now look
there's a lot of genuine victims out
there I know people have been to women's
shelters
and 90 of these shelters like obviously
look there are genuine cases and look
they need help and support they should
have it here but I know men that have
been to shelters to visit their kids
their children have told them stories
ninety percent of women in these
shelters are there so they can get
government housing they can secure
finances through the government because
the government will dish out money to
those who have claimed abuse especially
female victims
so these shelters are full of women who
were trying to get the council house and
to do that you have to place the abuse
card
and just to highlight something else
right about child maintenance you have
to understand why why the lost contact
why are there so many hurdles child
maintenance services and this is in
their mandate you can check this out the
less contact the father has the more he
pays
that is the key factor you are rewarded
for reducing contact so even if say a
mother thought you know what I'm not
going to put my children through through
this I want my children to have contact
with their father he can have overnight
stays as soon as he has overnight stays
she'll lose two three four hundred pound
out of that maintenance if father has
overnight contact yeah so what's that
going to encourage they're going to
think well I do want him to have contact
but I don't want to lose 400 quid so
forget it
as long as you reward the system rewards
loss of contact with children
Society will gravitate towards that it's
as simple as so
the child maintenance comes in
and if you don't pay that they can go
into your bank account and take it they
can go into and they can take you
straight out of your wages before it
even goes to they can take it from your
employer employer too so then oh sorry
sorry so then next you you wait the year
right because the restraining order is a
year so like what happens when you get
to court right okay this is all before
court right yeah if you're lucky no you
could go to court to represent yourself
but they could just stamp it off and say
right you're done for a year so then for
a year you have to live like this and
just try not to breach the order now I
know a lot of guys who have just tried
to make contact to get access to their
children because the the order says
you're allowed to make contact to see
your children
but as soon as mother claims abuse for
some and for some reason police have
enough resources to send people out and
take you away put you in 24 hours into
cell yeah after this so if you reach out
to your kids during the year yeah she
could say that you abused her yeah the
keys is you understand if she's the
she's got the children here for you to
see your children you have to make in
some formal manner you have to make
contact with her because she's got your
children
if in that process she says I didn't
like the way he spoke to me he was
threatening XYZ anything or she gold you
and you succumb to it you'll be done
you're done I know guys I've just made
contacts that can can I please see the
children that was enough I I spoke to
one guy two three weeks ago and this is
a well to do guys a very successful
businessman he spent a week in prison
I'm talking one week in prison but she
claimed the harassment or something and
it was just a text message I said look
please can I have the kids this weekend
something along those lines and when he
went to the judge after a week the judge
looked and said why did he go to prison
who put him in but this is the family
court Madness that people have no idea
because what it is you have this
delusion that we're in a first world
country this is England we have laws
orders processes procedures you enter
this system and you realize it's an
absolute shambles
so what happens
um so yes after that so he he reaches
out to the for the kids and she'll
either say he abused me or I mean she
might let him you don't know she might
let him but what happens is for you to
have meaningful contact you then have to
apply no sorry this is where the next
this is where the next situation wait so
why would he I just I don't understand
one thing why would he go to jail
legally he can reach out I did because
of female the only logic I can assume is
is certain I'm not anti-woman or
anything like that but as soon as a
woman starts screaming and chatting
abuse
as the society you just turn on you're
done
you've got no chance and it seems to be
this is what I'm saying when I say
family called matters they seem to have
so much leverage I cannot understand why
the women have so much love yeah and the
court seem to reward this and I fully
don't understand why but but this is the
next stage what happens in that year so
you've got no you've got no access to
your children let's say you've got a
molestation order against you you've got
no access to your children so you then
apply for what you called a core
application to see your children it's a
c100 application
and this is where the scam fully starts
now I'll explain to you where the whole
scam Starts Now the whole thing is a
scam you are emotional you're upset you
don't know what's going on you've got
this restraining order you can't see
your children so you then go to see a
solicitor
that's when the solicitors the
barristers that everyone around the
whole family court machine they're all
in on it together because your solicit
will look at you see how much value you
have how much a state you have how much
savings you have as soon as you walked
into that door that solicitors known
knows that's 15 to 20 000 pounds secure
he can't guarantee you anything you
cannot guarantee access to your children
or nothing but because you're emotional
you're upset you have a primal urge to
want to see your children
and that is exploited because they will
say to you we need to do this this and
this we need a five thousand pound
retainer literally before you know it
you've handed over 15 to 20 000 pounds
but the the lawyer and the Barrister
that you employ cannot do anything for
you and I know many cases I spoke to
fathers their own Barrister has said to
them
except the normal the allegations on the
order just accept it yeah it won't make
any difference they've said that
then because they've done that on the
advice of the Barrister they have had to
fight the fact that they've accepted
that order throughout the rest of their
case but they're saying why did my
Barrister say that because when you
accept the order 10 minutes in and out
barristers made his two thousand pound
and he's created you so many problems
down the line that you're gonna employ
barristers for the next two or three
years okay so I just want to make sure I
understand it so you go to the solicitor
and if you choose to fight the order you
spend fifteen to twenty thousand yeah if
you fight the order yeah the
non-molestation order and if you put an
application in to see your children
you're looking at like I said fifteen to
twenty thousand pounds at least okay and
typically that doesn't have a good
outcome right they cannot guarantee you
nothing and I'd go as far as saying the
solicitors and barristers are in on it
because they also take you've got to
send the solicitors viruses that are
representing you probably also take
legal aid and represent the other side
and many other cases so when you go into
court from all the stuff we're talking
hundreds of fathers that we've spoken to
now what it turns out is your lamb to
the slaughter because every stage of
that Family Court machine costs money
they are literally there to fleece you
it generates so much money so and the
end so this is even more crazy because
at this point you don't have your house
you're paying child support and on top
of that now you have to come up with 15
to 20 000 pounds yes if you want to
fight the order or you they just say you
can't do anything and to accept the
order yeah but that causes more problems
down the line because that now I'm
assuming that's a guilty yeah basically
yeah that's basically saying you're
guilty but the point is this about about
that yeah is you can you're emotional
You're vulnerable You're all over the
place right and you've got the solicit
as an embarrassed that's also taken
advantage and fleecing you so yeah
because you're I mean I would be very
crazy I would be going nuts what that
right there is where suicide comes all
of those stages I've explained right we
say it's one thing when you live it and
walk and talk it live through these
things there are days where as you spoke
to many people they've given up they're
broken they're broken men they've given
up and suicide does look like a very
good option yeah because at that point
you're at what age would you say this
typically happens 40s 50s that it could
happen at any I know guys I speak to
guys in their 30s guys in their 40 but
the older you are the harder yeah so so
let's say let's say you're in your 40s
or 50s you've worked for 20 years you've
gotten yourself to a certain point now
this woman Lee most of the time women
leave so more likely more likely than
not she leaves and she files a
restraining order and now I'd imagine
your reputation is ruined because
everyone once the abuse card is planted
on you in the community even your in I
know cases where it was so convincing
right some of these people look you know
like somebody like in certain cases that
I know of is there's an element of a
personality disorder
that they genuinely believe they are the
victim when you talk to these people it
is very hard not to believe so you see a
woman screaming and crying add to that
say from the communities you'll go with
a beard and that and say oh he's hitting
me he's abusing me he's berating me he's
forcing me to wear a hijab on X Y and Z
it is very difficult not to believe and
especially because the women's Aid
shelters have a whole storyline that I'd
imagine so like if um you said you're
you're a Muslim yeah so like for if I
was in a Muslim Community I would be
like oh that makes sense I know him him
and him that happened too as well or her
her and her yes and since it's all the
same story it's like more believable
almost so so first of all his reputation
is destroyed then he loses everything he
owns so he loses his house then on top
of that he's paying child support so he
lost his friends yes he lost his
financial like he lost his money and
because you're so all over the place you
could even lose your job if you're
depending the type of job you're an eye
actress because of the nature of the
work I was in it was dangerous for me to
be working I had to pack up work
effectively so you could potentially
lose your job and you lose your kids
yeah so you have no contact with your
kids for a year and you're coming to
these solicitors who are just ready to
take even more money from you and
oftentimes there's no incentive for them
to give you good advice they string you
along they they sort of how can I put
they string you along 90 of the times
and I know cases where guys have gone
completely against the solicitors advice
and they've won so then I said but why
would your solicit because what it is if
they keep you on edge you're more you're
more prepared to hand money over because
you think you're on the edge you think
you're going to see your kids if you
were told look there's no point there's
no point spending this money you're not
going to see your kids better you were
present you do this this and this take
this way out they're not gonna that's
fifteen twenty thousand potentially
sitting in front of you so you keep them
on edge and then if it goes into a
financial order later on that's even
more money so they keep you from what
I've seen they keep that emotional state
of flight and fight they keep you there
they won't you know calm you down and
give you that direction so what happens
if he does the guilty plea is that he's
never going to see his kids no you will
you no I wouldn't say you could still
potentially see your kids depending on
how your case pans out right yeah don't
get me wrong there's many horror stories
but there are a few successes and
sometimes some people do
come out of it okay as in they have some
content but there are so a lot of people
when you're doing that for two three
years it is so emotionally draining so
it's financially mentally emotionally
draining during this period of no
contact your children are being
alienated as well so a lot of fathers
I've known said I had a great
relationship with my kids even during
when they had contact they said we got
along so well kafka's got involved in
Social Services they interviewed the
kids and the kids say something
completely opposite because they are
coerced into it the the allegations the
brainwashing the alienation has kicked
in so then when you end up in court
because what what Studies have shown is
let's say I lost contact a year ago yeah
for argument's sake
that period of no contact whatsoever has
already done the damage so then I fight
through the court system for the next
two or three years by the time the judge
grants contact the kids are sold damaged
and alienated their kids the mother
dances it's not me they don't want to
see him
because they start creating she's been
talking [__] for years when I say
talking [__] I'd go further it's even
further the damage of Parental
alienation is more than talking [__]
right yeah talking [__] is one thing
it's understandable she's angry she's
upset but when you create dependency on
the child as in oh you know your dad's
left but don't worry I'm never going to
leave you I'll imagine a small child
they're going through that trauma and
pain of suddenly not seeing one of their
parents
then when the mother starts reinforcing
it with love and affection that's more
dangerous talking [__] is one thing is
still bad enough here it still does
damage but when you reinforce that with
love and affection that mummy's never
going to leave you don't worry have an
extra dessert I'll always look out for
you I know your dad left but I will
always love you don't worry Daddy's got
a new family
that damage into children I speak to men
in their 20s as soon as I mention
contact with their father
a barrier comes up and they shut down
alienation is damaging lifelong damage
and point is after two or three years
you've battled you've got through you've
survived at that point your children may
say I don't want to see you
because that the core the family court
allows such a period between any result
the mother's got free reign to practice
if it's a newborn versus a
three-year-old like that's a completely
different kid the kids already like most
of your brain development is the first
three years it's done I know kids I know
father I spoke I bumped into a father
recently on the street he recognized me
from one of my videos he said he's got
contact with his two sons but his his
daughters won't talk to him so I asked
him how old they were one daughter was
20 and one was 18 but he lost contact
three years ago I said but hold on they
were still at an age where they had they
understood things so they were in their
teens well into their teens but because
of that lost contact he goes even then
at that age even in those teen years
they've grown say grown women they're
teenagers 16 17. they were still even at
that age they said no we don't want to
see that anymore
so I always assume alienation if you
catch the child before say the age of 12
right yeah there's more chance of
alienating Stronger Yeah you could
alienate him harder but now I don't
realize you can still do this at 16 17
18. I I did an interview with a chap on
one of my podcasts a few weeks ago
his eldest daughter is now 17 right here
this guy said his daughter helped mum
alienate the other two children
he goes the daughter took the Baton off
mum and ensured the other two children
he had contact with lost contact as well
so that's how powerful alienation is
and he's now the guy so destroyed he
said I'm probably never going to see
them again and he has a resentment to
his eldest daughter she goes she's 17
18.
she engaged in alienating my other two
children against me he's now got that to
contend with as well so that's how
powerful alienation is but the core
allows for all of this the family I
don't know why or what the overall
agenda is but the family caught
categorically allow for this because
there's so many hurdles and barriers
placed all along the way there's a
domestic abuses perpetrators program
here
only for men in the family court so even
if a woman is convicted of domestic
abuse in a family court she doesn't have
to go on a program
that is only for men there's another and
that also costs thousands again
every there's a hurdle place that every
step wow I mean it's the horror of it
all is when you and when you know this
is what you're up against most men give
up they give up along the way they're
broke
they write a letter into the court
saying I'm done I'm out just for my own
mental sanity for my own sanity
otherwise
they'll end up you know potentially
drugs drink suicide
so the demanded with the domestic abuse
perpetrator program would that happen
before or after no that's during that's
later on in the court process on top of
on top of Child Support oh yeah yeah
when do you go into the court right
before you even going to cook what does
that cost I'm not sure but I know it
costs potentially a few
I can't quote exactly it doesn't have to
be just guess I've somewhat the last
person told me that they went was
potentially about two grandmas two grand
depending on how extended it is and also
the other scam as well so just to add to
that you don't talk about cost again
yeah there is a place if the judged and
allocates if you've had a long term no
contact with your child what they say is
it's not safe for you to have contact
with your children yourself so you have
to go to a contact center the contact
center costs 100 pound plus an hour
so okay and then they say you have to go
to the context and every two weeks every
free weeks every four weeks so for to
see your child you think all right it's
just another 100 pound another 200
pounds you have to pay every step of the
way and this is what they're saying the
fact Matt O'Connor and some of his
research I spoke to Matt and his wife
Nadine there and they reckon with the
research they have done the family core
industry generate more accumulated
wealth than the defense budget 70.1
billion annually 70 is that in the UK or
UK UK 17.1 billion and that's the
defense budget they reckon the family
court system the acrimony the separation
you have to get a separate flat more
furniture at my point it keeps the
system going and the barristers the
solicitors and all these organizations
along the way at that all the legal aid
that is claimed under these allegations
you add all of this up
we're going into the building they they
reckon potentially close to the defense
budget like I said 70 billion
so why would anyone want it to stop why
would they stop this
yeah so
can I go through so you do the
the court application and you go to the
lawyer and they say you're you either
take the plea or you fight it and so
even if you do get your kids after you
fight it either way whatever route you
went
it'll still take you two to three years
a lot of the time not always it's
normally they said it's normally a year
but since these delays have come in
since covert I know guys even forget
even the delays I know pre-covery what
happens as soon as you make progress so
let them just put another way let's say
the court orders contact the urine you
start having contact you have to
interact with ex on some level if she
then claims abuse again you've gone back
to the stop
wait so okay so you you do you wait a
year you see your kid finally you fight
it whatever then if she does it again
you have just you start over she can
this this she can start all over I know
guys that have gone through the whole
system I know men that have lost contact
for over three to four years
he got to the end he got the judge saw
through all of this finally sort of
started getting to the end
and the best he was going to get was
mediation she refused to come to
mediation starts kicking off again you
have to go for the whole thing again
that's why you and so you know what I
say deadbeat dads they never thought you
have got so many hurdles and barriers
you've got
I can understand why people give up that
could be the only option sometimes
because after three years you might have
to file again for Access again let's say
you could have contact even for a year
so after three years you've got contact
for one year this is the other thing
that happens with most men that I speak
to you
they've got contact they've gone through
the system year two years they've got
contact they've started making a
meaningful relationship with their child
they're a year into the relationship
with their kids then they meet someone
they meet a new partner the ex gets wind
of it guess what the game start all over
again because you have a new partner
yeah she hears about it and then she she
does this again so you turn up yeah you
start at the beginning all over again
and then that's another even if we did
on the low end and it was six months
that still even if we said which I think
you said the typical is around a year
say used to be a year I know it's a lot
longer but average they average it a
year even now year and a half officially
now it's a year and a half but even if
even if let's just say it was six months
like he got on the low end it was six
months it's still another six months he
has to go through this and another load
of money money yeah you have health and
this is what I'm saying there are so
many obstacles about and this is they
have made it so easy for the I won't
even say I'll say this for the party
that claims abuse right and takes action
first they have made it so easy to do
then they get the kids hypothetically
but they still might have to do a
domestic abuse perpetrator yeah there's
many there's another couple of they've
got so many other courses and hurdles
let's say you go through all of this
okay yeah they've got two or three
courses like this I believe here and
they to show Goodwill a lot of fathers
just go on it do it just to show good
what's look George I've done it they
then right at some point the missus can
say oh look he's on drugs you have to go
and do a young customer drugs test
there's there's so many hurdles and
barriers along the way and
if he was on drugs or drinking it's
probably because of this yeah I mean I
would drink yeah no toys yeah they
should bring it on man yeah that's all
he got yeah like you have nothing yeah
no it is is soul soul destroying yeah
this whole documentary has really
changed my view on homeless people no
because because honestly I really came
from a place of if you're homeless it's
your own fault so dude I swear to God
I'm not I'm not gonna lie I've seen
homeless people I just assume junkie
occasionally give a little pound but
look of it on junky yeah right I now
realize I sort of sit I walked and I've
now talked to these homeless people I
know how they got there because I'm
technically one of them I'm effectively
homeless I've had to walk with these
people here and I look at them and I can
see why 80 of homeless are men eighty
percent I mean when's the last time you
saw a homeless female I had to sit there
and think I've never seen one I have
never in my life seen a homeless woman
ever then I realize why and once I've
entered this I've realized how men get
homeless I was even told at one point if
you get convicted I think I don't know
if it's the family caught the criminal
court of domestic abuse your name goes
on a register up and down the country
with all the councils you will not get
housing you're on your own even if
you're down and you're like you will not
be given housing if you're labeled as a
domestic abuser so you're literally just
surviving on the streets or friends
relatives people's mercy and handouts
this is literally how you are and the
other argument is this because if you
have a property in your name and assets
here
even though you need all of that to
fight this you don't get no benefits
there's no support for you you're done
would you explain that so you know
government I don't know what they call
it in America you know America or
government give
um people money you know how kind of
benefits yeah benefits yeah so
government give you benefits if you're
unemployed you get child benefit or
unemployed unemployment benefit or
something like that yeah
because you've effectively got assets
and you've been made homeless the asset
is still in your name until all of this
is resolved here you may not be entitled
to anything from the government
so you're literally every door is shut
and in the community generally it's very
hard you know to put your hand out and
go to people for support or well
especially when you're known as an
abuser yeah it is about the I can't even
cover the the embarrassment and the
humiliating factor of all of this and
this is why
genuinely a lot of guys they get to a
stage and they say enough is enough how
much can you take every every father
that's gone through this has
contemplated suicide
but this is horror this boy I'm sorry
just to add more moving you know the
family quotes and this order that is
served on you
if you tell anyone about the orders or
it gets out that is a breach of the
order and you get put in prison so you
can't tell anyone this is when I say
destroy you through litigation you
cannot tell anyone about the order what
is it for why is it against you you
cannot give details about it so you are
silenced and the family court is a
secret Court there's no cameras there's
no scrutiny there's no jury
lives are destroyed behind those doors
literally
so how how are you able to talk about it
if I'm talking about the system I mean
not specifically talking about me
well I can talk about what's happened to
him I can't do details because if you do
talk
to Jail the family court is a secret
quote so now go back to what I said
initially so 41 lived in this country
how did I never know this
how is it that men only find that when
these things are served on them but all
the women knew the blueprint they had
the blueprint they knew it and the other
one is I know a father who keeps
repeating this one word I've heard them
on a couple of podcasts he keeps
repeating his own experience here came
home from work one day Mrs kids
disappeared gone he's panicked he calls
the police light I don't know where my
wife and kids are and this word that he
keeps saying I can see he lives this
every time he says it he says your wife
and child are safe and secure you need
to seek legal advice that is it come on
from work one day bang that's it next
thing you know he lost his business he
fought and fought and fought and he got
his kids in here and he got full custody
but it's these Horrors that no one hears
about and my point is how was I so
unaware unprepared and had no
understanding that the system is this
oppressive against men
because it is kept they've kept they've
somehow kept it so quiet because it's a
secret family court so can you what do
you mean so when you go to
I haven't spent a ton of time in any
Court no none of them I got caught up
with a fake ID once
in college
um but
so is a normal Court that's public
anyone can go to it so if I if I went to
criminal court and I and I wanted to
accuse you of abuse and we went to a
criminal court that would be public
that'd be great because that would
require evidence number one you're
innocent till proven guilty in a
criminal court you have a jury you have
a lot more people scrutinizing it in the
Family Court there's no jury there's no
scrutiny there's no cameras there's no
public
there is just you the judge and and a
lot of cases where I know just you and
the judge no no it's worse than that a
lot of the fathers that I know I've gone
in the father is on his own he can't
afford any representation so he
represents himself secondly you've got
to remember no evidence is required
these are just allegations in the Family
Court yeah you're you're you're if
you're a man you're guilty till you're
proven guilty in the family court is
just how it is so I know a father for
example I know many fathers they've gone
in to represent himself on their own
they had a female judge they had their
ex Mrs there they had the women's a lady
there and they had some other lead they
had their legal aid lawyer and a legal
aid Barrister so this one guy had five
people against him and if they're all
women unfortunately who were you know
when I said the radical sort of feminist
ideology where they're pushing this
um a general abuse yeah so there's one
guy on his own he got these five two of
train experts solicit and embarrass
against this geez
they get for free you're on your own
because you can't afford it guys have
got angry and frustrated at the
oppression that goes on and when they
get angry they're like see judge we told
you he was angry look he's got anger
problems he's getting angry now and then
they just guys have just walked out they
sold you couldn't write this stuff so
the family court the issue with the
family court is that it won its secret
there's no jury and it's to the
discretion the judge has to decide and
oftentimes the judge would you say most
judges are like feminists and have
feminists I don't think they're
feminists but I think they're so out of
date and out of touch and first there
has to be some higher order in there
that has told them they pandered to the
madness this is why I do not understand
you think you're gonna be they were
grown-ups and say look he disagreed on
the color of the paint this does not
make him an abuser it's like so you this
is the sort of thing that happens and
people can't understand like how the
madness is right so one guy for example
when he said yeah I disagreed with this
we had an argument and I disagreed I
don't agree with this the judge in the
end sort of said so basically you could
have agreed with her but you chose not
to because you wanted to control her
he's like sorry what like ah this ain't
happening you just you're standing there
and you're thinking is this really
happening no it's Madness so my question
is like the judges are individuals so
I'm just I'm just wondering like why is
it so one-sided because I'd imagine like
if we walk cause the power as I said the
women's Aid Lobby the whole
but the woman's movement is so powerful
there are so many connections and there
they they Leverage The Family Court so
you're going to send a family court was
designed as a paralegal told me that for
child protect under the child protection
act yeah
the certain group has studied that whole
law around child protection
they've taken out exactly all the
loopholes and what they need to do and
from that a blueprint has been
formulated by this organization very
powerful very organized that
organization is so powerful so they've
leveraged the court fully to one way
and when you're a man if Society is only
coming over now to realize that men can
also be domestic abuse there was that
presumption that domestic violence man
is the one who's the oppressive one
there's always been that presumption
up until recently I've subconsciously
it's a subconscious surprise I believe
that if for example I saw for example
I'd put it another way I'll make it even
personal let's say my sister comes home
crying and screaming oh he beat me he
did that looks wonder you're
automatically going to think oh poor sis
what happened why do you do this yeah
yeah it's just a natural for men
instinctively
you know it's interesting since I
started doing my show I've kind of had
this shift because when girls would say
they were like I'm going to say great
because I can't see it on YouTube like
great abused anything I at first I would
always just like believe them because I
wouldn't think anyone would lie about
that but then I would start to ask more
questions like did you go to the police
did you do this did you do that and then
like they would all say no and my
thought I'm like if somebody graped me
I'm going to the [__] cops like you
would not catch me like if someone like
if someone abused me like if someone
punches me in the face you would if this
doesn't mean let me give it to you about
Elegance like someone allegation that
I'm of and many people loads of guys he
tried to strangle me and he killed me
nearly killed me and I passed out that
was so many years ago what did you do so
you carried on sleeping in the same bed
living in the same house but now the day
you decided to leave or he decided to
leave he tried to kill me
listen if someone tried there is no way
you would sit on that without like
someone tried to strangle you it just
wouldn't happen but these allegations of
abuse are so I kind of put it when you
question the thing is this when
someone's crying and their emotional and
they're saying it is very hard to pin
down the detail and this is why I say
with all abuse allegations
press on the details and from what I've
noticed in my community this is element
of personality disorder where people
genuinely believe they are victims for
some reason it's prevalent in the Asian
Community now because they've got this
chip on their shoulder for generational
trauma or however things people have
grown up because of the second
generational trauma I'm second
generation agent in this country how my
parents grew up and how their diet their
relationships were very different to say
uh Mine and Ours would be here
so when I think girls have seen these
generational issues because father was
generally the head of the house so my
father his father they were men were
they did lead the household there was
that cultural figure
but as times have shifted and culture
has shifted here that is now seen as a
bad thing so when you walked into your
marital home
you automatically got that Stockholm
syndrome where you're already looking
for some sort of Oppression and this is
where I I like coercive control
allegations of abuse this generational
trauma I've now studied that and when
they believe these things combine that
with the fact that the blueprint was
already there
put two and two together
you think the girls do it with malicious
intent or do you think it's more of like
a brainwashing
it depends on the case a lot of which
bit the going to the family court the
Molly station order
I think for some reason women I think
look emotions are high
relationships are great you've got
broken down and the the law so your
emotion I think there's a vindictive
element to it number one yeah which I
can almost understand to some level
you're upset and hurt you know [__]
happens right yeah
but a lot of the other cases that I know
of here is
um they they've not done it through and
they how can I put it because of for
example the last guy that I interviewed
you last father I spoke to
his Mrs when social they were married
before pre-social Media One social media
Instagram and all of that came out he
goes is Mrs got influence into thinking
through social media people putting the
best versions of themselves that I can
do better
I can do better than this guy I don't
need him I don't need his money I am
independent why am I living like this
and they've walked out effectively but
once you've decided to walk out or end a
relationship for whatever reason we're
thinking well hold on how do I come out
of it good
they go to straight away then if
something they have access to that
blueprint
and most guys end up with everything
I've said to you they have that
blueprint but the last guy I spoke to he
blamed social media so his relationship
went completely down and then she
decided to eject a lot of the fathers I
spoke to even in my own Community now
where my community was known for
marriage they were very strong marriage
and marriage and family unit and those
values they're no longer there the women
are ending relationships I'm walking out
presumably they feel they can do better
but once they've decided that how do you
go out with the maximum gain children
finances and home and they just see it
as an opportunity blueprint is there why
not
and so the difference so in the family
court
um it's in secret there's no jury it's
just you and the judge and because you
don't have any or
the women's Aid per like the she might
have the women's Aid part like basically
representation she's got a legal aid
solicitor and a barrister she might have
two or three or four people with her
including herself you are on your own
because because she filed first because
she's a woman she's filed she's claimed
again you've got to understand the card
she's played the abuse card yeah she's
now secured X Y and Z all the way okay
you were fighting now uphill and the
judges are of we call it like in my
space of YouTube you might be familiar
maybe not we call it like more of a blue
pill mindset right yeah yes yeah 100
yeah that's exactly what it is yeah
where they they've really we've grown up
in a society where we never question
women women are always the victims and
so the the judges oftentimes either are
maybe they might have feminist ideology
or they're just more blue pill and so
they Pander even if you're old school to
a certain way you are blue pill I am I
what I am effectively to a certain
degree because generation are you a blue
pill because again up until I got
exposed to all of this I've assumed like
you saw a woman crying yeah die standing
next to her now this one said when you
add to the family you've got guys
standing next he's got a hat or beard
which is a big black guy or is a muslin
guy what a bastard he must be abuser is
that automatic subconscious bias that
you have and the judges have that all
the way through yeah and I know I talked
to the Mackenzie friends and the
paralegals who represent men in court
and they said they've said it as well on
the last podcast I was on the guy said
it he goes soon as the mother even puts
on the tears in court because it's not
going her way the the judge's position
completely shifts because he doesn't
want to upset mum and we've turned it
now turns out even in the Asian Muslim
Community he was strong on men and
masculinity the mosques and our own
leaders our community leaders they won't
touch this subject
categorically they won't touch it they
even refuse to put posters up that
support men and represent men in court
because they say we don't really want to
upset the ladies it is affected even
though everything that's our money right
because I'd imagine like church to at
least for I don't know much about the
Muslim Community but Christian it's it's
more female oh I see okay so that would
make sense there no in our community I
think it's just the backlash from the
country we're living in because it's Pro
blue pill okay and that's what I believe
that's what I believe it is ultimately
so but in a criminal court it would be
more tough to do this because you'd have
to convince a whole jury yes and you
have to have evidence you are innocent
till proven guilty and you need evidence
in the Criminal Court Family Court
there's this is done on a balance of
probability so say you're adamant judge
I did not do this they will say right
take five of these allegations let's
study them they interview the social
services interview you they interview
her and they sit there and they say on
the balance of probability we believe
this happened
on the balance of probability they'll
say yes you disagree we understand but
we do believe that the altercation and
you threaten to kill her that doesn't
make any sense because
the child care like the access to the
kids and a balance of probabilities like
that that's actually something it is
shocking this is so to contemplate this
and make sense of it as much as I know
about it I still shot myself every time
so okay so you go
parental alieny so then you go through
all this if you go to Family Court and
you win she can still just start it over
again okay if you win and you've got
full custody you become the resident
parent then you've got more clout then
you can say right you've got more clout
if nine out of ten times father just
gets contact she remains as the resident
parent resident care of the children so
if you say get what they call reasonable
contact is every other weekend midweek
contact half of all summer holidays
Christmas holidays and all this sorts so
like six days a month
that is a good that's a good case listen
that's a success story really six days a
month yeah let me tell you that that is
a good outcome yeah wow that is a very
good outcome in this because that's
exactly the re and this is what I'm
saying the position is so far
I'm telling you that's a good outcome
you understand that and what happens is
then during that period let's say you
don't play ball or she doesn't feel like
you're playing ball or guess what she
just wants to get back at one guy and I
knew she just wanted to get back at him
start it all over again so you go up to
you you turn up on the weekend to pick
up your kid
oh they've gone out where'd he gone
they're not here all these little games
start before you know it she calls the
police and say oh look he's being
abusive and threatening because he's
angry you get angry you don't see your
kids where are they it's my weekend why
aren't they here you get angry she calls
the police please come take you away she
can apply for a new molestation order
the whole thing could start again
and so really your only outcome where
you wouldn't have to keep dealing with
this for 18 years is if you get primary
custody if you get primary custody or
you're at her mercy effectively and how
much she loves her child if someone
genuinely loves their child and does not
want to damage their child yeah
oh you'd like to think they won't engage
in this year for the greater good of the
child and they co-parent but I know I
know one chapter I know one case
specifically yeah
when he after three years he wrote Into
the for one of his children he he gave
up he said look no more Court I'm done
I'm out I've given up once he gave up
[__] taking her to court to get
access a few weeks later she let him
have access and he said well why I don't
understand she goes I don't see you
squirm anymore so it's no fun anymore so
I don't really care that is that it was
that's what happened to him he's lost
contact in the end but these are the
games that are played because the option
is there even if you're a reasonable
person when you're upset someone's hurt
you the option is there to do this
you've got leverage you're done so yeah
because so if she feels Rich you know as
women we feel different every day yes
but if she it's the right day and she
just feels super angry we have the
option to put a guy through hell
basically and ruin his entire life yes
and if he I mean he could have done
nothing but like I'm just thinking of
how women think if he cheated or if he
spent something she didn't feel like you
should expect anything anything that she
feels is that brutal yeah yeah she I'm
not saying it was that brutal but if she
feels it was that brutal no but a system
is that brutal that that's all it needs
that's all it effectively means and then
a good outcome is six days a month that
is generally deemed as good six days a
month half of all summer holidays
Christmas holidays birthdays midweek
phone call that is deemed as a good
weekend you're basically an effectively
a weekend uncle and that's again and the
other thing is whoever she dates will
have more influence over the kids your
kids are gone look like might look I've
saved I can say this the last time I saw
or spoke to my children was 16 for March
2025 I don't even know what they sound
like now yeah and you know the skin
they're less than a mile up the road how
is it possible that I cannot see my
children that are one mile up the road
how how what sort of society is this
where I cannot go see my child without
getting in further trouble
because if you do if you do this
barriers and hurdles because if you do
she can just cry abuse I'll be if I go
to school yeah let's say I rock up at
the school gates for example yeah just
to see my kids um and I hate to say it
but the old school Mom's Club this the
teachers at the school some of the
teachers at the school ultimately once
that abuse card has come out you're a
monster effectively yeah
I rock up at the school Gates I'll
probably do 24 hours in the cell that's
it
done I have you are literally controlled
through the system the family court
machine is fully aligned against you
so I want to talk about the people the
people behind it so there's the women's
group The Lawyers the barristers oh you
those are barristers that's what law is
embarrasses are part of the same what's
the difference between those I think I'm
trying to think in American term so in
America you'll have the guide actually
talks in court and the guide actually
does the paperwork and oh yes so the
first guy you see at the office ain't
the guy that stands there and talks do
you see what I'm saying I don't know but
it's the same group basically yeah same
group there's the women's group The
Lawyers and the barristers the women's
group you've got to understand the more
people that walk through their door
that's they get government they get
funding they're government funded but
there is there are they different than
the child support group that's a
different group right oh child yeah
that's a different machine yeah Charles
CMS are a different group so you go
understand so you've got the women's
group you've got the lawyers and
barristers you've got the child support
then you've got the police who
effectively worked for the courts the
police are aligned with the courts here
please and so the courts is completely
different too yeah yeah police there's a
police are separate to the course but
the police effectively work they work
for the court there again family court
but family court is completely separate
yes yeah yeah and you can also add to
that social services the kafkas social
services where do social they fit in
with the family court so they're another
department of the family court
they're in family courts yeah okay and
they're effective they're you're
literally fighting a monster
okay so I just I'm gonna understand how
the groups interact with each other so
the money comes from our kids so it
starts trying to explain this right so
the women's group starts and they get
their government their government funded
their government government-funded
organization right okay so I'm just
trying to follow that to that they have
a lot of little sub Charities and all
they're basically they're now a very big
machine on their own financially that's
a lot of money going back and forth to
the women's Aid is a very big powerful
machine here that's the money Trail
starts there okay so the money starts
with the women's group they give money
to the lawyers they give the blues no no
they don't I don't know who pays the
barracies but the legal aid come from
government so the women's Aid
help the um
the one making the allegations secure
the legal aid so then that legal aid
goes to the lawyers and the barristers
okay that's that's what I thought so but
essentially the lawyers and the
barristers I'd imagine have an incentive
to appease this girl yes because they
get the most money from this group right
I'll go as far as saying the back hand
is going back and forth fully they're
both in on it together they're in
underscam yeah so then the lawyers and
and the barristers get the legal aid and
then add to the look The Lawyers and
embarrasses they get the legal aid from
one party when you go to try and fight
these allegations and make contact to
your children they get money from your
personal savings as well okay so that's
another money Trail coming in there so
that's the personal
savings but that that's separate but but
they're always going to get more money
from the women's group so their
incentive to the women's group they have
to yeah the women's groups send the
clients yeah they secure the money from
the government the lawyers but they send
the clients through the door and give
them the stamp and so they have to
appease the women's yeah because the
lawyer it doesn't appease the women's
group then they stop getting clients so
I'd imagine if he if you came in with
your ex-wife and you both went to the
the same lawyer they would have to
appease your ex-wife more because
otherwise they wouldn't get like the
most clients I'd imagine because they're
free each case that walks in you can
imagine this right each clear case that
walks ineffectively for the whole
duration of the case that legal aid Bill
affect who's nearly 25 30 grand
so every woman that walks in through
that door
the lawyers and the barristers will get
legal aid 2015 from the government so
they're all sales okay so then then
child support where did they get their
money they get their money from you the
Father the thing fathers okay
independent organization people think
it's a government organization but it's
a private contractor working for the
government independent
and they get their money through you
they make money off your child
maintenance well who hires them the
government the government so okay so
independent organization but they work
for the government yeah so people think
it's a government organization their
website's a government website but it
turns out yeah I've found out recently
it's an independent contract but so they
get money they don't so they have an
incentive because men make more than
women on average so so they have an
incentive to
to yes to discriminate against fathers
because because otherwise they don't
make money and as you said before they
need to keep that group happy they have
to keep the top group The Women's Group
because think about it their mandates
child support mandate is the less
contact father has the more father pays
so do they have do they talk to the
women's group I believe from what
research I've been women's Aid leverage
child support you've got to understand
look if a woman's angry and upset and
she's more likely to not give contact
more money goes through child
maintenance because like I said if the
less contact father has the more he pays
who does that whose interest is that in
don't worry man and who if I'm paying
more money into scene there's more money
going for child maintenance's accounts
and sometimes what happens is if the
women are really angry CMS deduct money
at your wages they tend to take a 20 cut
at your money they get 20 if they take
money straight out of your account so
the more acrimony the more money child
support make if you make came to a
private arrangement with your ex and you
paid her directly and even then also the
other thing with child support is this
let's say I was paying her cash every
month yeah because I'm doing my bit for
my key with a reasonable arrangement
tomorrow she gets angry there's no
record of this year
she calls up child maintenance he hasn't
paid oh yeah we split up a year ago they
will back date you a bill for a year the
cash that you pay there's no record
you're done
there are so many angles that they can
pull they have so many weapons that they
can use and and it doesn't matter even
if you can't even and you can't even
fight that because in family court it's
up to a jury and no no no no it's worse
child support and nothing to do with
family court child support child
maintenance you know CMS so how how does
CMS is an independent organizer is
nothing to do with family court so one
days when you say but look I don't even
see my children nothing to do with us
sir you need to go to Family Court child
maintenance are not connected directly
with any of the organizations you've got
to remember that they're an independent
body therefore purely to say you need to
support your children we're taking money
out of your account or you need to pay
this this we've calculated you have a
child your parental responsibility
that's what the law is they've got you
so anytime you go to work or progress or
do overtime I know guys I won't do
overtime because as soon as they
accidentally go over that next threshold
their money will be bumped up by another
300 pounds
it is absolutely brutal
okay so child support so how does child
support know how much they're supposed
to pay because child support have access
to your earnings so they look at your
bank account no they have access to your
pay government tax documentation they
know everything everyone what if a guy
was paid outside of like cash yeah yeah
then they can't do that they can't child
support cannot touch you if you pay um
obviously if you're doing cash in hand
number one or you work via some sort of
self-employed limited company then
you've got more options but ultimately
soon even if you work for a limited
company if you have a pay slip of any
sort that's given to you by any company
so for example you give a blessing a
payslip of some sort to say he's earned
this much or maybe you don't pay him
okay right so for example there will be
a tax record on there child maintenance
CMS have access to the taxes you pay on
the government record they know exactly
how much you and most guys say are
average blocks paye they're part of the
government system their employees
they've got you if you don't have a
skill that can be you can be paid in
cash in hand you have to go to work
they've got you you will screw they've
got you on every angle unless your likes
to have a limited company just for those
watching out there who are in trouble if
you can start a company work under a
limited company it will give you more
options but if your normal paye they've
gotten you live in poverty you live
without contact you walk around with
trauma your only option is drinking
drugs and the whole system just grinds
you down until you're beating
how does the police factor into this so
the police who like where where does the
money come from the police police
there's no money element with the police
the police are just there you're gonna
understand the police work for the
government these are government systems
and organizations they're just slaves of
the system so they're because but in a
way they're they're they have to appease
the women's group because the women's
group is government funded and child
support is also government funded so
they have to appease these two groups
yes they appreciate those groups but
more than that what they do is police
are also effectively
from that blue pill mindset men report
abuse and domestic abuse it is not taken
seriously men they are laughed out and
most men don't report it they say 40 of
male domestic abuse is not reported and
those that are reported are not taken
seriously
unless you've got a serious gaping wound
on you or something it's not you're not
taken seriously men are not taken
seriously so as much as the police are
just slaves of the system they're
awesome they're also they have I think
the organization is blue pill
effectively because you come to a house
like I said you see a big strapping guy
and you see a woman screaming and crying
ultimately it is very difficult to not
react to that so my question is why
wouldn't the police like
so I when I started doing my show
um or like looking at this content I
started in more of like a blue pill
mindset but upon like dealing with more
and more women I was like oh my God
these girls are lying like they're not
they're not telling the truth like and
especially when it came to abuse and
there's actually one girl that came on
my show and it was it was really crazy
because I remember like when I first
heard her story there's just like I
remember asking her if she went to the
like she said
that or the dad doesn't have access to
her kids anymore and I said well did he
abuse them and she said no and I didn't
really press her on it yeah but I was so
confused later and then months later she
comes back and says please take the
stream down please please please and I'm
like [__] no like
and I was I was she was irritating me so
much I was like let me find your baby I
didn't because I I don't know I don't
know who she's with you know I don't I
don't know but like now and I'm learning
about this it was probably because she
went to court yeah and I doubt they'll
even find the street like I have so many
videos on my channel what are the odds
he he finds the stream that she says I
didn't abuse him like he didn't abuse
the kids but I I figure in hindsight
like that's probably why but like why
don't the police have that like moment
where they they they've done this for
years let's talk about America I speak
to a lot of guys in Texas yeah and
whatnot right I speak to one guy in
Texas right
again Texas being Texas America being
America the amount of obviously fathers
access to guns and the violence that is
coming from this frustration they're
turning the guns on themselves you know
he goes he doesn't even make in Utah
Texas he doesn't even make mainstream
yeah it's for some reason in all the way
and this is the same what we're talking
about is the same in all the Western
countries for some reason I speak to
guys in Europe Canada and the guys in
America have said police turn up they
are effectively automatically on the
side of the crying doting mother simple
the female it's a society thing it's a
cultural thing the world is still in
that mindset of it's a crying woman we
need to protect her she's obviously a
victim yeah and until like until I
entered this whole Arena
I can't see it just it's sort of in
front of he's right under your nose but
you cannot see it it's like when you say
you came in as a normal sort of just a
blue pill mindset here then you kept
listening to these stories and something
triggered inside you and you [__] you
shifted you're thinking for a hold on
this ain't right what I can't understand
is how is that secrecy maintained where
it's happening under our noses I can't
see for example I think now this summer
right all the people I know in my
community are going to get married and
settle down they have absolutely no idea
of how easy it is that their children
can be I look at a guy with a father now
down the street and a partner playing
with this kid and I think does he
understand how easy it is for him that
kid to be taken away from you until you
enter this you can't see and I don't
know why and it has to be because it's
kept secret
and this whole bloop your mindset I
think everyone has every man has some
blue pill mindset on some level or other
we all are mothers sisters I've got
daughters do you see what I'm saying
these are naturally built-in thing but
it is built into society
and so where does the family court and
Social Services tie into this their
money comes from right no yes or their
money comes from government I suppose
the social services are paid from
government yeah
so there are hundreds of people working
in that in these jobs they're paid by
government now kafkas are the social
services social workers that work for
the family court basically yeah they
work in Family Court Arena child contact
that sort of thing
but I recently found out these kafkas
officers those social
social workers they're trained by
who do you think the women's group
and I'd imagine most Social Service
workers are women yes I'd imagine most
of them and women and what a lot of guys
have said to me even solicitors have
said to me that if you have a when I say
social services label it as Kafka that
is the name of the organization
the early Social Services for the family
courts that's the organization now most
of the loads of farmers I've spoken to
right here
loads of cases here
they have said categorically you could
get unlucky if you get a guy coming as a
social service officer you got lucky
a lot of guys have said women you come
when they happen to be women
they think it went okay but the stuff
they come out with and they basically
side ultimately with the resident parent
which is the mother they say they're
non-biased because their interest is
only the child but there's thousands and
thousands of cases and you cannot tell
me they're all bad fathers and they only
needed to reduce contact I had a case
recently I was speaking to a father
recently the other day yeah he's a
police officer he had allegations
labeled against him suspended from the
false right this is a police officer now
yeah judge went to court everything for
one year got access to his children seen
him in a contact center
then Mrs I think claimed some more
allegations or something or other he had
to have a cafe interview with the with
the social services to court Social
Services kafkas came down his misses
right
showed the kafka's officer a text
message of a story of an incident that
he had to write up on his phone and send
him to work because he's a police
officer there was an incident with some
case violent incident so he had to write
down the details and send it off to the
his station his Mrs got hold of that
message and said look this is the sort
of stuff he's engaged in he's a police
officer so the kafkas lady said yeah he
engages in obviously this sort of
violence due to his job
this he might be a danger to the kids
I'll stop access
he's a police officer like of course
he's got
well today so this is the madness I
wouldn't a judge even saw and said hold
on why are we even then the judge
questioned the kafka's office and said
why are we stopping contact because of
one text message
but someone made that decision my point
is the Kafka Services looked at that to
say nope you're a danger to the public
your danger to your children because you
are a police officer so we're going to
stop contact
this is the sort of Madness that you're
dealing with
so I just want to know why the family
court system like why is it so Secret
because if it's if this all comes out
into the Open The Money Train might stop
number one number two once they're
scrutiny and people like for example
once you see this madness and you think
hold on this like I said I'm 41. I had
no idea this is going on under my nose
in this country we live in here how do
you keep it secret
that's why you know it's one thing I've
noticed
um I take Ubers a lot and I've noticed
like I've started asking my Uber drivers
if they've had any issues with the
family it's a lot of them yeah I would
say like at least one to two out of four
are like guys that have been screwed
over in court big time the surfing I
can't understand you know if me and you
were talking about this now and I've
seen this horror and I thought I can't
sit by and do nothing here
the last 20 30 years all the fathers
that have lost contact and gone through
this I'm shocked that there's not been
major rights and stuff like you know do
you know what I mean even the stuff I
hear that goes on in America and the
family courses I think is even more
brutal how is this allowed to go on in
all the Western sort of countries this
is going on
so who pays the family court who pays
the judges government to run the day the
government the government the judge gets
two grander hearing so I hate to say it
but judges they make a lot of money so
why and the government but oh I talked
about this with the fathers for justice
guy
Matt he said it's because and now the
government has to Pander to women
because they won't because they won't
get
elected again if they don't Pander to
win so there's no incentive that yeah
this is what matters see I remember
Matt's interviews years ago and as he
said it
what they said the highest voting again
don't quote me on this year I remember
this from Matt's interview so far the
highest voting population is single moms
who's going to go against them
and women's eight is a very powerful
organization they women's Aid you've got
to understand women's eight have lobby
lobby government and got these laws into
place
they Lobby government they have a lot of
Leverage and like Pat said the highest
voting population is single moms
hence this is going on under our noses
yeah it's shocking in it so what
happened to you so I know you can't
speak everything so just tell me what
you can what I tend to do is I talk
about a client that I'm representing and
what happened in his case right yeah
okay so this client of mine I'm
representing he was married for 10 years
right yeah now for multiple of issues
personality disorders and other sort of
issues of that nature
his children were being alienated under
his nose now people assume alienation
only happens once you separate yeah
coercive control I believe I'll even put
this out there bluntly I believe more
men are being coercively controlled than
women yeah even though the stats say
otherwise because I'll say eighty
percent seven percent of his men don't
even know they're being controlled now
for example can you explain that yeah so
for example like this one client of mine
right
his children every time he wanted to do
something with his children for example
right so he wanted as his kids were
growing up you wanted to take him out
take them to his mom's and you know
Grandma's house uncle's house all of
this stuff
there's barriers put at home very subtle
so I said oh I was just about to do
dinner time
I can't take the kids now every time
this father wanted to spend time with
his kids or take them out shower time
bedtime is homework time and you can't
really carry it out on for so long so he
said but why is it every time I'm doing
something with the kids there's an
obstacle when you're at home you don't
see or when he used to come on from
night shift this one father specifically
right yeah these are coming from night
shift he never used to go sleep so it's
kids used to say Dad Dad take them to
school drop us to school so what is Mrs
used to say to him was he goes she said
oh look you look really tired babe maybe
you should lie down for a couple of
hours he's like no I'm fine no you look
really tired why don't you lie down when
you come back I'll make you a nice
breakfast and he's like he said yeah
you're right I am feeling tired he lays
down for two hours he doesn't actually
sleep but he misses out on that moment
because she controls the school pickups
and drop-offs that moment with the child
is very special the pickups the
drop-offs they talk how was your day
that little bonding moment she wouldn't
allow him to bond she wouldn't allow
members of his family to bond with his
children so one day he realizes his
child was eight years old at this stage
right here
his child said why how can we not play
with our cousins and brothers and
sisters from your side of the family
then it turns out his child doesn't even
know the names of his uncles and aunties
eight years old that can't happen under
these family live or live nearby his
family lived nearby that cannot happen
overnight now when you realize a child
is does the guy I know this is happening
he knows but subconsciously there's an
element of when you're in a relationship
with someone who's unpredictable yeah
and this unpredictable person has your
children this unpredictable person looks
like a victim to the world you've got to
understand somebody's narcissist
behavior and personalities they look
like a victim they are a victim they
convince themselves they're a victim and
this is my point no one is going to
believe you so when you challenge this
at home right
how do you challenge this how do you
challenge someone with a personality
disorder and unless you've experienced
interactions with someone like this
you're living in a prison of your own
you're trying to manage yourself but you
think as long as I'm around I have some
input into my children's life it got to
a point with this client where this
control around the children got too much
it's now affecting the children his
children started telling him Mama's a
bit funny ain't she why you know why
can't we go to our grandparents house
why can we not play without relatives
and cousins
so then he tried to stand up for issue
now you can't say something to this
person because they're the main care of
primary care of your children you have
to go to work it's a very fine balance
but one day it is for enough is enough I
have to do something this has to end at
least what if I end it my contact with
my children will be my time I will bond
with my children I'll have a meaningful
relationship
bang next thing you know the family
court machine activated all of that bang
bang bang bang bang done
and there's one specific case that I
could tell you about right so
24 hours day you split up 24 hours in
the cell arrested questioned by the
police various allegations of abuse
historic allegations going back 10 years
right
few days later you were landed with this
molestation order because she is killed
legal aid there you are now landed with
a smallest station order followed by an
occupation order so you can't go to your
house you're done
then you are left literally wondering
aimlessly on the street right yeah just
surviving
because of the nature of this client's
job he couldn't work Dr signed him off
it's unsafe for him to work electrics
high voltage he'd kill himself and other
people he cannot work in this
environment career is done yeah after
that he has to put an application in to
see his children now there's some major
delays in the court system he's still
waiting to get his first hearing to go
in and even put his case forward and
that's a year forward
he's just left out in the system living
like this he has no and just to add to
that
all of his clothing his tools all of his
personal belongings are in his house
he's got limited clothing he's living
out of a van and just surviving and
hustling literally just to get by you
were left at the mercy of the system
right
and one more thing I would add to that
was um also we're talking about once
these allegations are labeled against
you the community turned against him
people from his own Community came to
Rob his house and take stuff out of his
ass on the say sort of his ex even
though she was living there so
I can't explain it but it is
every aspect of your life is turned
upside down and you are expected just to
go about your business on the street and
I don't know survive
my personal story one year molestation
order still running left out living out
of a van effectively
and hustling just to survive
do you think that the deadbeat dad is a
myth
I believe so because until I came into
this I heard all these things and I was
thinking what a horrible bunch of men
don't want to spend time with their
children
I think that that beat dad is a good
rhetoric to have once you've alienated
the father he's got no access he's given
up he's not a deadbeat I think it's all
this whole man-bashing element of it all
now I can see I never understood right
here
until all of this happened this the blue
pill red pill masculinity I had no idea
of any of this I never understood it
because it's all sort of under it's done
under your nose you don't see it you
know the law is not fully with men but
you don't realize it's this extreme once
I entered this now I understand the red
pill movement the blue pill movement I
understand these arguments of
masculinity and X Y and Z but before
this
I had no understanding of any of it
because you are literally dehumanized
love father safety in this country now
you've got to understand yeah if you
find a homeless dog on the street they
will give it shelter they will give it
food and they will protect it a father a
man has less rights than a dog here that
is a fact
you were left literally on the street
is there anything that can be done
I think the first thing is exposure
until we expose the secret family courts
and it comes out because what people
don't realize here is what the way I
look at the family courts now is I've
survived look I might be okay here I've
survived I'll get by I'll do whatever
yeah but the kids that are coming up now
let's say my son when he grows up will
he survive this system
this I cannot see and this is what I'm
saying I see my my nephews and my nieces
if I look at all the boys in my family
and I think will they survive this I
think we have a duty if our children are
being kidnapped literally like this
denied contact with their parent they're
being alienated and damaged yeah
and single parent families they've
they've demonstrated Studies have shown
in England and Wales alone eighty
percent of the prison population are
from single parent homes now if the
government are happy to sit by and
damage these children my kids your kids
all these other children here we we have
a duty to do something and I think the
key thing is we're lucky we're in it
we're in the age of social media I think
exposure exposure exposure Tilly gets
into the mainstream and what I'm doing
myself personally just to put it out
there because the Father the problem
with the father I tell you why the thing
with the women's Aid and what we said
yeah they lobbied the government as one
unit so you've got the main unit you've
got all the subgroups that feed into the
main unit the mothership the mothership
lovies the government the fathers and
I'll say it straight the father's group
all the fathers groups they're
completely fractured
there's people making noise here they're
there they're not United and this is
what I'm calling for all the fathers
groups and movements they need to unite
and lobby as one they need to put their
agendas aside pull together lobby as one
if we're to make change in our
children's lives that's the reality and
I'm trying I'm working behind the scenes
they've started a farmer's Alliance
where we're getting different groups
together like the CEOs these are
intellectual people we're getting all
the CEOs of organizations together
who are then and these are intellects so
they're Bankers
um people from professional backgrounds
who have ended up in this and they know
the system they're going to work
together hopefully now
to try and Lobby government and I'm
hoping that platform grows and if these
intellects can pull it together then
we've got a chance but as long as the
movement is fractured
I think it'd be very difficult
so when I talk to a more blue pills guys
um the common response I say I always
hear
um like because we talk about a lot of
these issues like on my channel right
and their response is always you guys
just you're picking the wrong women
why don't you just pick the right girl
okay right no okay my counter argument
is this year
what is the right woman what is the
right guy what is the wrong girl the
thing is you understand so the behave
the society the behavior in society is
governed by law
if me and you say went out now right
yeah
let's say we decide we had a child for
example we've now had a we've got a
child right
we've suddenly hit a rocky road
in the back of your mind you know your
backstop to any situation negotiation
your position is the government will
back you you will have the child you'll
have the house you'll have the finances
I can potentially be thrown out you know
that's your backstop so we've now had an
argument that we've had an argument
about the color of the paint again
I am adamant that no I'm not backing
that you're not backing it's going to
come to a head but back your backstop is
though still I'll have the house I'll
have the kid I'll have the finances and
I can choose a color or the paint you'll
be out the door I will act accordingly
because I know my back stop is I'm going
to lose everything
so the behavior the laws in society will
govern the behavior oh so they almost
incentivize the behavior and
relationships so that's why we always
have the phrase like she wears the pants
yes because how could she not wear the
pants when she has all the leverage in
the situation exactly and that's why
like the men aren't going to leave
because then they would
um they would lose everything where she
gets everything exactly so my argument
to these blue pill guys is all of these
women that they're talking about what
they were all bad they were all bad
women they weren't bad they were normal
potential women and a relationship went
bad it went wrong because that's life
[__] happens but when that happens like
you said women are more emotional
they're more hurt more vindictive guess
what they've now incentivized and said
yeah you're right you are a victim he's
a bastard what he disagreed with you
there you go there's nothing would you
say a lot of these girls are like like
are there warning signs that they're
gonna do this would you say or it could
it be anyone I think I honestly believe
because look I look I speak to guys who
have been sort of come from an arranged
marriage love marriage marriage is from
abroad marriage is here and the other
thing you've got to remember this if in
the family court right
there's there is no racial religion in
the Family Court every person from every
background to every man from every
cultural religion and background and
demographic has come come up against the
same attack now let me tell you about
when you say good women yeah you talk
about my community women that wear
hijabs Jewel Bob's cover up you know
they're sort of they present themselves
to be religious people in the Family
Court they're on the front line
there are religious fans so-called
religious families from my community on
the front line going totally against
what the religion says because when it
comes to family call there is no
religion no race no color it's all left
at the door and when you say good women
bad men how what determines it was a bad
choice
maybe it was a good choice but [__]
happens people relationships end but
when one person has the power and the
leverage and they're incentivized their
incentivized financially
they're going to do that do you think it
would be the same if it was the other
way around I think it's possible it's
definitely look I'll be balanced and say
this I think it's possible but I don't
most men that I know yeah
relationships ended there's a logical
element of look [__] happens let's move
on I love kids my days you'll have kids
on your days I think look you're right I
agree with you actually I don't believe
it would be because I think most men are
logical
well [__] happens look let me put it
this way if I was prepared to sacrifice
the rest of my life and live in my
prison for my kids here
where else would I be prepared to do for
my kids so ultimately I don't think
you're right I think most men are
logical I don't think most men would go
down this road because she's still the
mother of your kids even if you split up
ultimately this is your baby mama so to
speak yeah if she's okay and healthy
your child will be okay healthy and safe
so you'd presume on that grounds I don't
think most men would you're right I
agree with you
how common is this out of every 10 guys
like it gets married how common would
you would you just guess I I'd say this
right considering look I came from a
community where marriage was strong I
never thought this would happen to me
yeah just as many did but it is so Rife
now is infected my community fully this
whole blueprint we've talked about
absolutely Rife I think if you're saying
how common is this
I think there's going to be a day now
when you say out of 10 it will be 10 out
of 10 everywhere every race every
Community everything you think it's
going to be 10 out of 10. it's already
Rife the Asian Community where we had
that marriage family unit
when this situation happens
unfortunately
what happens is when is for example so
look I can say all of this to you right
let's say tomorrow my sister stood up
and made allegations and I said yeah but
Paul she's legit she's genuine I know we
don't want to press on the details but
it's that element so what happens is
when it's your own family member
especially from my community what
happens is it's automatically a blue
pill mindset straight away no but she's
genuine because she's my family she's
legit it's okay to deny their children
because it's one of my relatives he's to
blame this blame game
hence I believe unless unless you've got
sensible people around you and my point
is when someone does this if they don't
have sensible people around them yeah
for example so you look you know the tip
of a girl goes to a friend saying oh
yeah my man he didn't do this he ain't
doing this he ain't doing that you've
got those friends that instead of giving
you sensible advice they all stirred
apart a bit more
I think add to all of that 10 out of 10
I think it's going to be Rife I think
when my kids get married if I make
that's if I'm invited if they know me
yeah it'll be this is going to last one
year two year three year five years be
lucky if you get five years out of it I
would say that's what that's the advice
I'll be giving them I think is because
of the way Society is the way the laws
are like I said you're rewarded for
certain things
it really
actually the
what you said about it changes the way
people interact in relationships because
that's what I was thinking how many men
really lead relationships nowadays they
won't but how can they it's like you're
in a business deal where one person has
all the power how on Earth could he lead
the thing is is look I say look because
that's that's always the other argument
too I hear from Blue pilled guys well if
men just lead it if men just were better
leaders this wouldn't happen see again I
just think
I think what people don't realize is
this ultimately when they say men can
lead you that's fine what does that mean
you can lead if you're in a normal
healthy relationship yeah that's an
automatic position that will happen you
wouldn't have to say I am the leader
you're the follower it's a normal
relationship you will respect your
partner you know in their strengths and
weaknesses respectively there if you go
down that road ultimately yeah and that
power shift this idea men lead so if
blue pill guys are saying what does that
mean what you need to assert your
Authority how
knowing the backstop we know the
backstop of the law and the Machine and
the family court machine we know the
backstop here how do you still then
leave knowing that you're going to lose
your forget the finances forget the home
knowing your own flesh and blood the
children are going to carry your name
will be taken away from you how do you
lead from a back foot
you can you cannot and this is my point
when you're dealing with but would you
say that's the same when because you say
most people don't understand the laws
how is that the same sentiment even when
most people aren't aware of this yeah
look even though I wasn't aware of this
oppression because I came from a culture
where once you are married you are
married you had children you sort of you
soldiered it out you did what you had to
yeah I was from that mindset knowing
that the law is still not on my side but
even then I rolled a dice here not
knowing that it was this oppressive and
this tyrannical you see what I'm saying
so even though I knew law wasn't on my
side the community wasn't on my side
there's you know it's still a bit of a
taboo in some parts of the community
being divorced and separated or leaving
you because effectively once you end it
there's there's no position of we're
both grown adults this ain't working we
manage our business deal with it yeah
there's an element of again this blue
pill mindset how could you do that to
her
I think hold on I'm the victim as well
I'm the victim here it's in music too
yeah you ever like you if you hear
listen to music like if it gets a guy's
song that's popular it's always like he
did something to her and like like even
in I'm a big country fan and that's
always the same story like I hurt her
and he hurt me yeah it's like so it's
even in our media too like if you watch
on TV it's always the male abuser never
the female abuser is and is done in such
a way it's like it's called conditioning
right yes yeah you're conditioned slowly
to believe it so for example I'll tell
you what my case directly
I knew for 10 years my kids they weren't
really my kids
I was so conditioned that I knew they
were her kids she had to say she had
Authority
her and her family decide what happens
well there was an element of when you're
sitting there and you feel like a
passenger in your own children's life
here that is an alarm Bell but what do
you do and when they say lead an
authority what does that look like
especially with someone who's
unpredictable this is what people have
no understanding of and this
unpredictable person has your children
you are you are you are hostage
effectively in your own life that is
what you are so when they say lead right
yeah it is very difficult to lead when
effectively look in our community there
are a lot of leaders there are old
school traditional Indian Muslim men
right they still live in that live that
life here there's loads of them in the
Family Court he's an extremist he looks
down on women he doesn't respect women
and the women on the other side are
accusing them they're wrong women from
their own culture their own religion
I've completely turned against their own
religion it says in in the Muslim
religion it's category he says you
cannot break your child contact with
their father it is a big No-No
when it comes to this year
because of the um like you said through
the music through the culture this
element of radical feminism
they've gone against their own they've
turned on their back on their own people
in their own culture
so when you turn around and say he's
extremist Muslim Mike and he's forcing
me to wear to hijab this you know like
I'm talking to my sisters that you
should dress that way from their own
family homes yeah they've dressed like
that their whole life they're standing
court now and say he forced me to dress
like this go send a judge she was
dressed like that before I met her so
like what were you going on about no he
forced me and that element of um
that so say for blue pill guys to say
that I don't know what that means I
don't know what that looks like unless
you the only way that can work is before
you get into a relationship and I'd
advise all all men secure your assets
cure your finances make sure you spend
time with your children recorded time
with your children before you get into a
relationship when you're in the
relationship this is during the
relationship before you get into a
relationship protect your assets your
Family Assets you have to otherwise you
lose leverage yeah hold on so I was
going to go through like what what can
guys do to avoid this so before you're
saying protect your family explain that
more so for example in the Asian
Community a father might have multiple
properties he's put one on the son's
name or put one on the other salesman if
that son gets married now and that uh
marriage ends in divorce that's his
father's or family's assets 50 gone or
eighty percent they can take away so
before you get married they need to put
the financial do not go in with your
eyes closed because Lord youngsters that
I speak to now they're saying I was just
hoping once we get married and settle
down things will be okay
I said what protection have you put in
place so you need to protect your
financial assets as in get multiple
names on the Deeds for example property
Deeds get framework put in place with
professional accountants to ring fence
the assets do you see what I'm saying so
they don't belong to the marriage
okay so you can get an accountant to say
it's yours not the marriage you can yeah
you can put Frameworks in place I can't
go into the exact ins and outs of video
but there's Frameworks that you can put
in place potentially to protect your
asset so they're not part of the
marriage and what I will say is if you
are to start a life with someone and
let's say your partners or say your
missus is a professional working person
make sure she pays 50 50.
because in our in our community what's
happened is right as a Muslim
perspective I'll give you yeah wait say
that again make sure she pays 50. as in
if you're buying a house together no
problem if she's a professional working
person like yourself then you buy it
together okay yeah so when you lose you
don't just lose your 50 do you see what
I'm saying you buy every so every big
asset you guys yeah pay 50 50. pay 50 50
because in the Asian Community there was
just a man was just seen as a provider
and protector and all that you went
worked hustle bought a house X Y and Z
yeah she and in our community what's
happened now as well well because men
are meant to provide for their misses
even if they're working you still say
give them a financial incentive as a
husband yeah those women from all can be
that don't practice religion when it
comes to finances they only practice
that bit of religion that financially
you have to do this you don't know
nothing else about the religion but that
Financial they're first on the table
with that one yeah so what I'll say is
don't fall for that trap and a lot of
guys unfortunately I think there's nod
along goal with it because they want to
get married
so what they then do then do is they
just you know they don't take any
precautions so if you're going to buy a
house buy 50 50. if you've got Family
Assets in your name make sure they're
removed off your name and your family's
assets are protected because then you
have more leverage if things go wrong
people are more likely to be sensible
are you with me when you've got all the
cards on one side then you know you're
at the mercy of one person so before the
marriage fifth pay 50 50 for large
assets does that include cars too
everything um protect yourself on
everything if this is if it's a
professional working person I'll say if
you're someone that was not working and
chooses to be the traditional sort of
housewife then fair enough yeah but even
then
within your assets make sure the
framework is there just to protect
yourself
okay and during the marriage you said
during the marriage make sure the time
with your children is very important be
involved in the school runs the pickups
the drop-offs when they go to the
doctors take time out and be with them
because when you just think that you
know you'll think you're in a marriage
for life I'm with this person she's got
my kids she's got it covered I'm gonna
work and hustle and do what I've got to
do she's got this covered here these
things will play against you and if
there's an element of she's
strengthening the bond with the kids
herself
and there's a classic one in our
community your dad was never here
because he was working I don't know if
that's a good thing or a bad thing I
thought that was a good thing personally
but your dad doesn't love you he's never
here because he was always at work
working to provide they don't tell the
kids that so make sure you take time out
and don't get so lost in this provider
role that you miss out with time on your
kids because because there's a lot of
hours I know they work you know days and
nights shift work days and nights and
weekends they've missed out on many
things in their children's lives here to
be able to provide for them so they made
that sacrifice
Mrs has then walked out done what she's
done and then they've lost contact and
lost everything so they've not just
they've lost that on all fronts and they
also last all the time because they were
the like the mom got the got the time
with the kids or he was sacrificing his
time to pay and then as a thank you she
takes the kids and his money yes and
this is exactly it so I would say take
time out have that relationship and bond
with you would you say to record it too
there's evidence like if it ever goes
south you have evidence of it in court
as sad as it is to do that in a marriage
or relationship I say yes do it I say do
it and if you suspect your missus is
gonna you know
if you suspect your Miss is going to lay
allegations on you or you feel there's
trouble you know you feel the waters of
trouble something's coming have a
recording device a small device or a
camera device with recorded evidence
here because like I said when it comes
to family court when these allegations
are laid against you they're very hard
to counter I know one chap when all of
this trouble happened in his marriage
unfortunately she accused him of rape
this the other one in Family Court as
well men are being accused of rape and
mistreating their children sexually
every these sort of allegations are
being placed against normal decent
blockchain now this father luckily he
managed to then get in contact with
Misses back and forth and she admitted
that she made that allegation up which
then saved him in the family court
because he recorded if he didn't have
that what how do you prove that if you
don't have that so I will say recording
devices record the time with your
children how much time you spent with
your children and make sure you have a
bond with your children soon so that
when things go sour that bond is what's
going to carry them keep them strong if
you spent less time there anyway because
you were working then when this
alienation starts you got no chance
when did you see I mean your client what
did your client see warning signs that
what how long did it because from like
again a blue pill perspective it's like
if this woman was a crazy narcissist how
on Earth did you get into a position
married with kids well my client likes
my community right the way we meet
people get married is a whole structure
and a framework and is there a time
where
where Society culture is slightly
shifting yeah it's in that period so he
met this person as you do in the
community came across normal and okay
family seemed okay he got married as you
do he got I would say really unlucky in
a sense that you can see it was like a
semi-arranged marriage it's a very
normal thing now that brings his own
problems don't get me wrong here but
he's ended up there once he's ended up
married and my client discovered that
there's something not 100 how long did
that take I think he knew straight away
really and you straight away something's
not right but in the community there's
that pressure once you're married and
you're in a marriage and also the thing
is this what okay we go deeper into this
aspect of it yeah so like my client and
many clients that I've spoken to have
said yeah
when someone is perceived as a weaker
person yeah so don't get me wrong when
when the blue cool guy say you should
have been a leader the position he had
was the leader this other position his
misses was that you could say the
subordinate or the follower she played
the
um she had that Persona of um softness
if you know what I mean uh feminine soft
Persona like she's not the leader yeah
but that can be very deceiving now my
client knew something's not
a hundred percent yeah
but when you're dealing with a
personality disorder you're in a
community where there's pressure to stay
together and so the point I remember I
was trying to make is when you yourself
start seeing someone as a victim
when you're in these relationship you
start feeling sorry for them you have to
understand people don't understand the
Dynamics of these relationships when
you're with someone of that personality
disorder they can show you that they're
the victim the classic line I had a hard
life
my dad never loved me I was never given
attention my brothers and sisters I was
singled out you start when someone keeps
telling you this
that you subconsciously you start seeing
them as a victim so you can see this
issue that's there
but then you start feeling sorry for
them then you feel guilty and then you
think oh crap and then when you're from
this sort of community where this
divorce separation very taboo very
awkwardly once you're in you're sort of
in as soon as you mentioned divorce no
one wants to know you so you're sort of
locked in yeah you don't think you have
any other so you carry on yeah now
combine that with the fact that you
start seeing this person as the victim
yeah just like the blooper when we talk
about you know woman crying screaming
you're in there you're conditioned now
imagine that conditioning over years
where you'd subconsciously want to
protect this person because they're a
victim even though you're being coerced
you know something's not right your
children are being controlled there's an
element of oh I can't do that to a wish
you're going to go what's she gonna do
she's a victim she's had a hard life
she's like this because of the problem
she's had but when you then look deeper
and understand it objectively everything
she's told you about all this other
stuff previously to me you know how do
you know any of that's real
my dad never loved me my dad never gave
me any attention all this sort of stuff
you start feeling sympathy once you feel
once that seed is planted of guilt yeah
you feel sorry for this person that
keeps you in the relationship
and every time when you again when you
start talking about problems in the
marriage it's that whole oh maybe I
should just end my life the suicide card
comes out and if you've got kids even
though you know this person don't mean
it you're just sort of think in your
head but what if my kids are there she
does something silly I better play ball
let me tell you I established control in
a relationship coercive control over a
Mania to all the blue pill red pill all
of them if you have a child with a man
yeah and you show here you demonstrate
your unpredictability around the child
as hard or as tough as that guy might be
he's gonna have to toe the line because
he can't be there 24 7 to look after the
kid remember this he has to go work or
hustle or do whatever he's going to do
remember and people don't understand
this when people say oh my woman won't
do that I won't get away with this I'll
do X Y and Z they have no idea what
they're talking about is because
men want to protect the kid above all
else so so they're gonna cater to her
because she has the kid how you control
a man this is how this whole blue pill
movement works here is if you can't
control a man one-on-one in a
relationship yeah so you're in a
relationship to get leverage over that
man yeah to lock him in you have a child
you're happy you're a happy family don't
get me wrong you're an okay family now
once you have a child for example I knew
this one client yeah they had a baby it
was around Christmas time yeah very cold
that's a minus two degrees outside ice
all over the roads so him and his missus
had a disagreement middle of the night
about something trivial yeah
so three four in the morning this is
this Baby's two weeks old yeah minus two
outside
grabs his baby in a blanket jumps in the
car in the pajamas Frost cold outside
drives off
he's just thinking like what do you do
what's going on
she'll come back in a bit
but there's a baby involved you start
getting paranoid you start thinking what
about the kid what if she has an
accident there's now this unpredictable
paranoia then you think maybe I
shouldn't have said anything
hold on maybe this is my fault if
something happens tomorrow this will be
my fault I better not say anything Mrs
he goes Mrs comes back after an hour
crawls into bed goes to sleep and
following morning hi babe do you want
breakfast like nothing's happened he's
thinking
okay like
what what does last night mean you have
once you demonstrate that
unpredictability
there's an element of he needs to toe
the line or be very careful because you
have no real understanding of what this
person will do is capable of and you're
in it you're in this relationship
so what happens is then you toe the line
you put your head down and you carry on
protect your kids
when you're in that sort of relationship
that is a bit different from like with
like from a normal relationship ending a
happy marriage that went sour and ended
is one thing when you're dealing with
coercive control personality disorder
and you see these guys they come to work
they head down they don't talk they are
broken they are prisoners in their own
life because when you're dealing with
someone like that who's convincing you
believe they're the victim people around
you believe they're the victim the world
believes they are the victim you have
zero chance
combine that with this system here you
are finished
and the sad part is too
like I always talk about on my show that
a lot of men are avoiding legal marriage
but it doesn't matter if you have a kid
it doesn't matter yeah I didn't do a
legal marriage myself thinking I'll be
protected in some way or of about to a
certain degree it gives you a look it
gives you a little bit but nothing once
you've got kids there's nothing once you
have once you have a kid you're at her
mercy basically you are you're
effectively out of mercy and that is
exactly how it is wow
this is the most messed up thing I've
heard that's crazy
yeah listen we could talk for hours
especially around all of this yeah well
I'm really sorry that happened to you
that's really sad I know it's good it's
good it happened to me the cameras are
watching yeah I ain't that guy that's
going to give up crawl away and die I am
going to fight this and I'm gonna like
so before this all happened to me up
until four months ago I've never had a
Facebook account I've never I missed a
Whole Decade of Facebook I was a private
guy I've barely had a thought of myself
here now hopefully I'm going to be
everywhere trying to expose this and
push this because we have a duty to our
children so whoever is watching you
ain't going away ain't disappearing
can't give a shout out to my kids I'm
your dad I love you sorry that one my
bad kids I'm your dad I love you as
promised I won't give up I will continue
to battle for as long and as hard as I
can and I'm prepared to go to any length
and distance and coming in the camera
nothing for me I'm prepared to go a lot
more for you guys so I love you I miss
you and God willing I will see you one
day soon
any kids I've got three kids and they're
now nines of bloody or nine seven and
four I miss one birthday each for each
child always last year so yeah so you
haven't seen them in a year and a half
when I say yeah it's just over yeah over
a year and a bit now and when I say not
to him not seeing him not spoken to him
nothing and they're a mile away they're
just literally up the road they are up
the road but it is
it is soul destroying but look I'm just
glad that I'm strong enough to carry on
about ultimately because you know
there's many nights where it could have
gone differently let me put it that way
yeah so but I have a duty to them I have
to try so you know
well thank you so much I'm like tearing
up no thank you for helping me thank you
for having me honestly I'm I'm
Starstruck and ultimately
so thank you so much for coming
um let me know if there's any other
fathers that want to be a part of this
documentary because I will try yeah it's
hard getting them out I've done a
podcast with a father the other day yeah
it's very comical here because he's
bellied up he's got Darcy's Glover he
doesn't want people we can yeah we can
do something where they're not it's just
their voice I'll try yeah I'll reach out
I'll try I'll try and grab them yeah
guys make sure you go follow his um
YouTube channel disqualified dads on
YouTube Instagram and Tick Tock please
follow like and share it's very small
it's all very amateurish but look the
message is getting people want to donate
is there anything they can donate to
yeah I haven't set it up here I'm gonna
get around to that so yeah please donate
once I set it up yeah guys I've not set
it up yet but yeah okay is it okay um
yeah just let us know so when we release
it we can put it in no thank you thank
you I will do I'll stay in touch
definitely okay thank you so much for
coming um guys make sure you like the
video on your way out so subscribe to
the channel and we'll talk to you next
time